Let's go ahead and get started. Thanks everybody for being
here. Hope everyone's having a
great reinvent. Uh, today we're gonna be
talking about one of the most exciting
evolutions in online gaming. It's the
migration of EA's Apex Legends
to Amazon
Gamelift servers. To be honest with you, this is really more
than
a migration story. It's a story about
the motivations, the challenges, the learnings,
and the solutions that really drove the transformation.
The hope is that um
you'll learn a little bit more about game
with servers and
what we really see here at AWS as
a shift in how multiplayer games are built
and scale.
Uh, quick introduction, my name's Trevor Moore. I lead the
relationship between Electronic Arts
and EEA.
Um, the real stars of the show, excuse
me, Electronic Arts and AWS, the real stars of the
show are the folks on stage with me,
uh, Tom Penrose, Chief Online Service
Officer for Code Wizards,
and Jared Cugno,
uh, head of technology for EA Apex
Legends. Quick
review of the agenda. So we're gonna start off today by giving
just some context to the relationship between
um AWS and EA.
We'll jump into the evolution of Apex Legends.
We'll give a little bit of a deep dive into
multiplayer games and the challenges involved with operating
them at scale.
Um, we'll chat more about G of servers and
some key benefits there,
and then we'll highlight the partnership with Code Wizards
and, uh, what good looks like when migrating
a live service game from one platform to
another. Wonderful.
So let's start off with a little bit of
background with, um, EA and electronica,
um, EA and AWS. How many times am I gonna do that?
Um,
it's a 10+ year relationship. At its core,
our relationship with EA really revolves around
three key pillars.
The first is it's a strategic partnership.
So EA is one of
a small handful of customers here
at AWS that we call strategic.
Obviously there's a little bit of a financial
aspect involved there, but
more importantly, EA plays a significant
role when it comes to how
AWS builds products and services, whether
it's a new region or
an offering like Gamelift. EA's voice
is definitely heard on
the AWS roadmap.
The second is innovation.
Something that we often talk about
with EA is
regardless of your role or title,
AWS is the platform for
innovation.
Um, moving to AWS, it's, it's not just
about saving money or
scaling up for a big launch, which we do
those things very well,
um, but it's about having the building blocks
to
stand up a net new business or
concept from scratch in days
or weeks as opposed to years.
Lastly is the player
experience. This is
a non-negotiable at Amazon we
talk a lot about being
customer obsessed.
At EA it's all about being player obsessed. So
you know, whether it's a POC
or a production ready workload.
Any conversation, any decision, any
idea always starts with the player in mind.
Um,
so with that said, I think, um, just to kind
of tie this all together
here a little bit, I think it's really important to understand how
EA operates as a business,
you know, they have all of these studios all over the world that make
amazing IP like FC and Madden,
Apex, Battlefield.
These studios, they all have the ability
to
pick and choose whatever technology they think
is best for their team. Oftentimes that is AWS,
but not always.
So generally speaking, EA operates
like a federation.
They're associated, but they don't always,
they're not always unified when it comes to technology.
On top of that, as we all know,
technology becomes outdated
fairly quickly,
um, I think which was one of the challenges I think that
Respawn was starting to face as they're operating this
super successful live service game at
scale,
um, but before we dive too deep
into the technologies and kind of the solutions
here, let's talk a little bit more about
Apex themselves, um.
If you're in this room, you're probably likely
familiar with Respawn.
Uh, it's the studio behind Titanfall, Apex Legends.
They were acquired by EA back in 2017.
The team was mostly made up of
ex- Call of Duty, Activision guys, a
lot of AAA legends, uh, super
deep understanding,
and really a proven ability to build
first-person shooter games.
Fast forward to 2019.
Apex Legends launches.
It was a really
interesting event.
The game dropped out of nowhere. There was no marketing.
There was no nothing, but it just absolutely
took off. I think it went from
0 to 2 million players within the
1st 24 hours.
Within the first month it reached 50 million players.
It's done well over $2 billion in
revenue for EA.
Apex Legends itself is a
battle royale style game.
It's really movement.
Based high twitch latency
sensitive, it's a live service game as
we all know, so
a lot of new content,
uh, new seasons dropping every 3 months.
If you know anything about Apex as well, um,
you know they have a very passionate fan base, right?
Um,
certainly a community that's not afraid to voice their
opinion, which,
you know, we all love to see, but, um.
I think what we observed around, you know, a couple
of years back and I think what was happening with Respawn and really
the expectations of
of the players was
it was starting to evolve and cloud technology
around this time, a few years back was
was changing. Game server hosting was starting to change
around that time as well.
Um, I recall sitting down.
I think it was late 2023 with
Jared in LA.
It was very clear that Respawn was starting to look at
different hosting options, right?
Yes, they wanted to
save on costs, but there were other kind of
key areas that they wanted to explore as well.
First was.
The player experience needed to be better, right,
so
meaning scale, but there were also
some ongoing issues and things with, uh,
you know, latency,
lag, packet loss was something that we heard a
lot about. There was definitely some room for
improvement in those areas.
The second was
The Respawn team, they wanted to modernize their hosting.
Um,
Respawn wanted better access to things like logs,
observability,
uh, they wanted to iterate faster. They also
wanted access to modern hardware, which
meant moving off of bare metal, obviously. I think one
thing that became super clear to me,
um, and the rest of the AWS folks was
that if Respawn
and Apex were to make a move,
uh, parity was not good enough,
right? Um, data,
uh, Jared made it very clear that.
They needed to have some real
data-driven impact to justify any changes
they were going to make to their their service.
Lastly, and I think this is a really big one, but it's
super critical for a studio,
uh, in general, but especially a studio like Respawn,
uh, to maintain developer velocity.
Um, Apex is certainly,
you know, again, they're pushing out new versions, new
updates to the game
into production.
Those launch dates, those new
seasons,
those dates don't shift,
um, so speed and agility is really
essential for a studio like Respawn.
So again, they were really looking for not only a
change, but they were looking for a technology that was going
to adapt with them
and not vice versa.
So with all that said again, Respawn really
looking for a new partner, a new platform,
really looking for an opportunity to innovate and
improve,
um, and the reality is I think you know
Respawn's probably,
uh, they're not alone, uh, probably a lot of folks
in this room are in the same boat,
um,
you know, these multiplayer games, they're hard, right? They're
really hard, they have unique challenges,
um, and before we talk about how
we solve those challenges and the solutions that we have
to. Uh,
to, to help you guys out, um, I'm gonna hand the mic
over to Tom
who's gonna talk more about the nature of
multiplayer games, what makes them so difficult, and,
uh, how we help to solve that. So Tom, over to
you. Yeah,
so, uh,
as Trevor said.
Multiplayer games are hard at that high level,
there's so many things going on with multiplayer
games to actually make
the components that allow players to play.
So if you look at here, this might be a typical er
a diagram of uh of what a live service games
look like, and this doesn't include all the components.
At the top there we've got the game back end,
so you've got services like entitlement, what
players have access to what weapons and
skins, what are they uh actually able
to access in the game?
We've got things like economy that drives
the live service model. What players have bought
what, what are they spending credits on, what is their bank
balance or their wallet look like. These things are so
important for the game.
We've got services that make the game fun, things
like achievements, leaderboards, ranked,
status, all these things that actually engage
players, um, and are, yeah, make the game
more exciting.
Then you have the kind of backend services like analytics,
er, what maps, what characters are
players playing the most of? All of these things
that kind of drive the decisions in the game, where
are players having fun, what are they enjoying?
And then finally you have services like remote
config which allow you to make those changes quickly
to a live service game. What damage does that
weapon do?
Uh, what maps are on rotation right now, what's
currently being played, so these things can be tweaked
without having to push a whole new version of the game, which
is again critical for responding
to those player impacts that we're seeing.
That's just one blob of of that live service
infrastructure, you've then got the multiplayer back
end which we're gonna talk loads about today,
the matchmaker, the lobby service, the scaling,
um how do we have enough compute online for people
to actually be able to play at any one time.
And then you've got all the stuff that happens behind the scenes,
the development environment, staging, QA,
CICD pipelines for being able to deploy
all of this really quickly, 456
builds a day so that we can test new features really quickly.
All of this stuff needs to get built into a whole framework,
which then allows us to get content out to players
as quickly as possible.
And with all of these services, any
single one having a slight disruption or issue
or problem means player pain. It
means players can't play or we can't get stuff out to
players quick enough.
So it's a hard problem to solve.
When we look at the number of players playing or
capacity available, we see
massive swings day to day. Each of these spikes
represents a kind of 24 hour period in
a live service game.
And this is normal to see things
like, um, time zones rotating,
different types of players coming on at different
types of days, uh, certain
maps rotating. All these things are just
our player base and how many players are playing at
once. It can also
be external things like
sports tournaments or public holidays,
other games going down and suddenly loads more
people are showing up in your game. This all
things we need to consider as part of the capacity
planning and how we adapt on a day to
day basis.
And then when we look at a more yearly basis
or month over month, we then see bigger shifts
in player dynamics.
So here are 3 kind of season
launches, and you can see here
when new content gets put out in a game, loads
of players show up, they want to play the cool new stuff,
right? Um, so we've got to think
about that and all the different capacity planning,
planning and deployment that comes with these
new season launches, keeping the game fresh,
keeping the game fun.
And then on the other side of that, if we're
not seeing players and we're seeing a decline for whatever
reason or slight shifts in that, we need to think
about bringing that capacity down,
protecting the revenue of the studio and making sure that
they have all the funds available to be able to put it
right back into the game and build the content.
Those pennies need to get spent on
how the player is
playing and enjoying the game and not the back
end things.
So of course whatever happens with all of these
capacity planning or different parts of the stack,
the player experience has to come first.
Our goal is the game, for the game to be up
24/7 in all time zones,
working efficiently. That's what our job is.
And for game servers, it's not just the capacity we
need to think about.
A game like Apex has a high
proportion of ranked matches, so we need to
be very considerate of things like latency,
location, how we're matching together.
Apex itself has an even bigger challenge,
which is 60 player matches. So how
do we find 60 players in different regions that are trying
to play in the right
game type, game mode, all these different
things go into matchmaking decisions which are just hard
problems to solve. So lots to think about um
when we are thinking about this migration.
So Trevor, do you want to tell us a little bit about the Gamelift service
product and and why this might be a good fit? Absolutely.
So how do we help? What can we do, right?
So let's talk about Gamelift servers. So
it's a service that's been around for a while. You've
likely looked at Gamelift in the
past. I would encourage you
to take a look at it today.
Um, it's a completely different product that's changed a lot over
the years.
Uh, we have an incredible product and leadership
team who's really driving the Gamelift roadmap.
So, um,
again, take a look at it today.
I'm really curious to get your feedback on it, but a little bit more
about Game Lift and what it is specifically. It's a purpose-built
game server hosting solution for multiplayer games, meaning
it's fully managed. It's a fully managed service. It
takes the operational burden
of having to manage game servers
off of the end user.
Right, so it's a service that's
built on the back of AWS. It has
global coverage. It knows how to scale.
We recently ran a 100
million CCU player test to validate
that level of scale,
and Tom's going to talk more about that here in a minute, but
it also offers
flexible hybrid options.
So some studios, they only want
to operate in a hybrid model,
so the service allows you to bring your own compute
if that's a requirement for you.
There's also a feature called Game Lift Anywhere.
Which is um a component where
you can test locally
so you don't have to spin up a bunch of compute, uh,
essentially just send a game session to your local desktop.
A few other things that I think differentiate uh
Gamelift here are,
um, there's a service or a feature called Flex Match
which is our matchmaking service built inside of
Gamelift
containers, this is another big one, but, um,
Gamelift now supports containers for
building and running, uh, game server packages.
Back-end plug-ins, there's a lot of new integrations
with popular game backends whether
it's
Pragma or ExcelByte.
Those integrations are baked into Game lift as well.
Telemetry metrics, this is also a really big one that we've
heard from our customers as well, but a lot of really
good data capture around.
Uh, Fleet performance, game
session activities, server process health,
things of that nature are all
what you can find inside a game lift.
This slide here really illustrates
the kind of global presence of
Game lift. So anywhere players
are playing,
we likely have a presence in that region
or that location. We're continuing to improve that
and likely this slide that you're looking at here
is probably outdated as of today because we're
constantly adding new regions, new zones
for Game lift.
I think by the end of next year we'll have about 55
local zones and regions that Game lift supports.
Outside of these regions, outside of these local zones,
there's also many different
instance types and sizes that you can find with Game lift.
So it's uh,
if you're looking for C class,
M class instances, those are all available with Game lift
as well, um.
So that's, that's Game lift in general and kind of just
a brief overview of the service, but I think now that you
have, uh, I guess now that you have an understanding
of what Gamelift is, how
it operates, how it scales, I'm gonna throw it
back over to Tom,
talk a little bit more about some of the data, some of the,
the graphs, and some of the things that we've seen in terms of
implementation and what that looks like.
Yeah, cool, thanks Trevor.
So I appreciate for some folks, er,
this looks like a very boring graph, but for me as
an engineer, it's possibly one of the greatest graphs ever.
Um, blue line shows the service availability
for game lift over quite a long period of time
against the green line which is their target service
level objective or SLO.
So what you can see here, um, rock solid
platform, no real problems at all,
and really built for that scale, um, and high
availability.
Same graph in terms of time, so uh looking at
the same time period, but you can see here incoming
request volume
to the Game lift service, um and what we talked
about earlier with the kind of player populations and
things spiking day to day, you can see that on the left, right,
you can see those constantly changing um.
Amounts of players and therefore incoming APR
request volumes,
um, but the thing that's really interesting here is these larger
spikes. These are seasonal launches,
game launches,
big events, um, and even
with this massively changing call volume,
still 99.99%
availability in terms of actually delivered
by the team, which I think is absolutely phenomenal.
Um, and not only that, one of my favorite parts about working
with the Game lift team is they're really good at shipping stuff.
Um,
I personally feel, having worked in live service
for a long time, it's very hard to ship new features
quickly whilst keeping a really rock
solid platform. What we typically see is when
new features get shipped, they're a bit ropy for a,
for a little while, um, whilst things
see with other. Platforms, but we just don't see that
here. So, um, some examples of some awesome
new features in the last 4 months SSM
in console. So if you're debugging a problem as a
developer and you've got an issue with one of your game servers, literally
being able to click a button in the UI and get
straight on the console of your Linux box is
just awesome, uh,
really speeds up the kind of developer debugging workflow.
Um, we've got Gamelift servers telemetry metrics,
so Gamelift already has a, a pretty rich monitoring
stack, but this is directly getting stats out of your
game server itself. So if you want to do custom metrics
and things and then visualizing them, um,
in places like Grafana, which is, uh, fantastic,
we'll talk a lot about observability in a minute.
And then we've got some other features like uh local zone
expansion, so getting servers closer to players,
uh, new OS support and uh updated
plug-ins for newer versions of things like Unreal, which is,
is fantastic to see.
So it was quick to see, or we quickly
understood stood as a team that Gamelift was going to be the
right tech choice for Apex, um,
but Respawn were focused on shipping
awesome game content and quite frankly,
they should be focused on the players and getting stuff
out. They didn't want to do a migration, right? Um, so
how are we going to actually get that done?
Well, we formed a bit of a better together partnership
between AWS and and Code Wizards.
Picking that rock solid high scale, um,
high performance service for actually doing the workload
itself, but also
game centric humans who know games, know
how to ship games, and can actually do a migration.
But not only that,
support the game and help improve the game
post launch. We talked about parity is not
good enough, so this was one of the things that we really
wanted to do is continue that improvement once we'd
done the migration.
So together we make a really strong package
for helping game studios run in the cloud.
So a few examples of that, um,
Gamelift already has a really great monitoring stack, you can see
that in the UI and have a look at your fleet overview
and things like that. We wanted to go a little bit deeper.
So when you've got a title that's already
running, there's lots of custom things
that have been built over the years which uh need
supporting and adapting.
Um, so we built on top of this
to give some of that rich monitoring like
things like per game session data,
overall game dashboards, custom
game metrics that are specific to Apex,
things like that.
And we built them already into workflows that they
were used to using, so that meant that the development
teams didn't need to adjust their
day to day work, working and they could focus on
shipping game content which was really important to us. So
this was a kind of a key part of the project.
And then we also needed to think about doing the
migration itself, right, and and building some tooling
to allow that.
This is things like um custom CICD
pipelines already built into their existing
uh kind of deployment flows. It's
the zero downtime patching process to make sure that
we could ship content out to players
without taking the game down.
Um, and some special migration
tooling to actually do the migration itself, which we're going to
talk, uh, quite a bit about.
Um, I wanna give a shout out to the Gamelish team here
actually. They built in as part of this migration,
some new APIs into the product for everyone,
um, which made this migration a lot easier.
Just specific ways of working with different
types of servers.
One of the nice things about the product is it's not,
um, er, you have to use it this way.
There's lots of different ways to use the product depending on
your game and, and your workflow and how you want to use
it. So
one of the key points we formed
early on in this project was everything we
did had to be about player experience.
So we had to take all of those different points that we were working
through and tie them back to how are we going to improve
this for the player, um, and not
just keep what what we had running right now.
So this meant that we spent a lot of time
thinking a bit differently about things like metrics,
deployment processes, how we were actually going to do
things to see if we could er er
build a, a better system really.
And then we also needed to think about post
migration, so we'd got the migration done, yay, great.
Um, but afterwards we had to think about
how are we're going to continue that constant
improvement, that continued support. Um, so
we actually, in addition to the migration,
helped out with providing a 24/7 service
with games operations expert to kind of keep the
monitoring, keep improving, finding those proactive
games and improving things over time.
The service is a mix of monitoring, alerting,
and ultimately super smart humans that
catch issues before players see them,
and that's been really great, I think long term for
us improving this service.
So let's have a look at the fun stuff, the actual migration
itself, um, 10 days, 0 downtime,
like what does good look like?
So we started with a bit of a very high level
uh plan, um we wanted initially
to build out a proof of concept.
What was that going to look like and could we actually
make the game work.
Then we went into a build phase, building all the migration
tooling, building all these things that were going to happen.
We went into a test phase and then we did the migrations
themselves, starting with dev and ending up in production.
So the proof of concept,
we started first with
3 kind of core pillars that we were
going to achieve to to prove to us
that this was actually going to work, that this was going to be something viable.
We started with the main flow.
Can players smoothly and quickly connect
to game lift servers and play a match? It was as simple
as that, right? Is this thing actually going to work?
Then one of the key points we needed to look at was zero
downtime,
the ability to patch the game
without disrupting players at all. So being able to
iterate constantly on game patches, get
content out to players, and not having to worry
about taking the game down or or changing any
player behavior um to allow
us to do that.
And then finally, and we talked a lot about this, metrics
and observability.
The reason why this was so important was because
we found it difficult to know
what's this parity thing mean, how can we prove
that we've done better, and we're all engineers,
right, we wanted to prove that with numbers. So we wanted to
start with what's our baseline, what does good look like,
and then we knew when we'd make a change,
what what and how has that improved things, and
that really helped actually with picking some of the
paths and decision points that we made along the way.
It also means that we could give
the operations teams and the developer teams
access to all the information, including some new things,
so they can react really quickly to things happening in the
game. Again, live service is all about
being able to adapt to the players.
So we moved past the POC and then we got into a
full project plan.
Um, so we mapped out all of the major milestones
that needed to happen. You can see along the top here,
all of the different parts that made up the migration.
Um, the eagle-eyed amongst you might
notice that the planning for this project was indeed a little
bit more than 10 days. Um, it takes
a lot of work to be able to pull off a migration
like this. Um, we say 10 days,
but I think we could have actually done the migration in, in
1 day or maybe even two.
We purposefully picked 10 days because we wanted
to do it slow and steady and
be able to do it in a really
kind of measured way, and we'll talk about why we
did that in a bit.
We had to get things right on the on the
timeline around um er
December holidays, but also around season
releases. We could not get in the way
of the team shipping content, so we had to think
about the migration and how that would map into all of
the content plans they had,
including doing season launches whilst we were doing migrations
and things like that. So
really critical as part of the planning
um and really important.
So we made a bit of a plan and then we got into the build
phase. So we started
by thinking about uh what the
right architecture should look like and how we should do
things. Um, we talked
at the very beginning about one of the key
parts of this project was we could not
impact respawn game development. They had to be focused
on shipping core content,
um, which meant no changes to the,
to the game server or the game client.
So that was one of the architectural choices that we were
making, no changes to the game itself.
So we had to think about how we were going to
design around that.
We worked heavily with the Game lift team also to
build something that wasn't just going to get them through
a migration and then they'd be landed with a bunch of tech
debt after the migration.
We wanted to think about what tolling could we
build to allow the migration to happen, but then give
points that we could then build on in the future
to make it even better. So we had to really think
about what,
instead of just
get them off their current provider and get them onto game lift
as quickly as possible, what did the future look
like? How are we going to improve this?
So first thing to note on the left hand side of this diagram
you can see obviously there's the players.
So um a player loads up an Apex game
client and they connect to a matchmaking
backend, so that's um er respawn's
game backend.
That then decides
who's going to play together, what matches are gonna happen,
all those different points of things, and then it
fires off an APR request to uh a
provider to say, hey, I'd like a game server.
The game server, the information for that
IP address, all those things come back uh
and the players can connect to the game server, so that's the kind of
rough end to end flow.
What we decided to do
was
a design that had two components.
The first component we called portal.
So you can think of this as like uh
an API proxy, um or
a kind of game-based load balancer I guess.
So it captured those requests from the Respawn game
backend, which was ultimately talking in the
it it to the API to the previous provider,
um, and we mimicked those APIs so that we could capture
incoming requests.
Um, we had the ability to then just transparently
proxy those requests through to the old provider, which
meant that uh we could essentially be
in the loop but uh keeping things as
they were. We then implemented
the SDK for um Amazon Gamelift
servers and that allowed us to set those
things up and we then had this ability
to be able to take in an API request from the respawn's
game back end and either send it to the old
provider or send it to Amazon Game Lift Services, so
we had a bit of control there.
On top of that, we then built a bit of software
that we called Switcher,
and its job was to be able
to very carefully and fine-grainedly
control where we were pushing requests,
so broken down by things like region
or even game type,
we could set a percentage of how many requests
we wanted to go
and where we wanted them to go, and that actually ended
up being one of the key parts of This migration
was so smooth.
Um, so, uh, an example of what this might look like,
uh, we set in a config file,
hey, in Australia we want 1% of
requests to go to Amazon Gamelift, and we want
99% of requests to go to the old provider.
And then we could adapt that on the fly constantly
to adjust when we were doing the migration itself.
Um, and that ended up being, yeah, one of the reasons
we could do it in such a controlled and slow manner.
And the second part of the architecture
was what we called the wrapper.
So once that requests made its made its
way down to an actual uh virtual machine
itself, um we then need to start the game server
binary to actually uh yeah, start the game.
Um, we couldn't implement the
Amazon Game Lift Services SDK in the
uh in the game server itself because again,
we didn't want the respawn team having to worry about
that sort of infrastructure. We wanted them shipping game
content. So we built a little go binary
that implements that SDK.
When the request comes in, we start a game server
and that allows the whole flow to happen and and
players to be able to connect.
So that ended up, uh, we initially were thinking that this
might not be a, a wise design choice cos we're
essentially adding another loop in the chain, right, but it
actually turned out to be an excellent uh decision
because we then had a lot of things that we could do externally
of the game server binary. Things like telemetry,
logging, monitoring, um,
a bunch of which already exist in the SDKs
in game of servers, and then we built on top of
those to add some even more, uh, rich
metrics and things like that for the respawn team. So it actually
turned out to be a really wise, uh, um,
architectural choice.
Um, for anyone who wants to give this a go, the wrapper is actually
open source. Um, uh, you can get it
on that QR code and have a look. Just allows you to
get up and running with Gamelift servers really quickly, so I'd,
I'd urge you to give it a try and try, try it out.
So we built a thing.
We had this architecture in place. We'd built
the code um and we were ready to go. Well,
we didn't want to go live without doing some testing, of
course. So, uh,
once we'd built all those tools, the serious testing
kind of started to kick off.
Um, and as I talked about before, it was really
important to have a baseline of what good luck, good looks
like before we even started.
So how would we, how
would we know that the low test is successful? Well, we'd only
really do that with data.
So early on before we started testing we set some SLOs
based on all the metrics we had from the game that was
currently running.
Some examples things like queue times,
match placement,
success rates,
you know, how quickly players can get into a match, all these
kind of things were things that we measured quite early on
and had a Rough idea of
what we needed to hit as part of these low tests.
Um, this would turn out to be really critical
for us because we could then measure what we were improving.
Uh we made this change, oh, it made it better, oh, we made this change,
oh, not quite so good, right, we need to try something else. So
that was a really critical kind of design choice early
on. We
took the overall testing plan and we broke it down into
three categories.
The first one being what we call component testing.
So going right back to the beginning of this talk when we talked
about the multiplayer game, um, kind of
overall system and all those different components,
we take a component at a time and we look
at how they're going to be run in production.
So what requests are coming in, what requests
are going out.
We use um a tool called K6 from
Grafana and we um use
that to build realistic production patterns
to kind of throw at services. So ultimately we're just flooding
a service with API requests and seeing how it responds.
Um, but again,
having that measurement,
understanding what good looks like and then being
able to adjust those um uh
tests on the fly worked really well.
So we took those components, that's portal,
the wrapper, the respawn, matchmaker,
all the different parts of the stack, game lift itself,
and then we threw these requests at them and see,
are we above our thresholds or below
our thresholds, are we looking good?
Once we knew each component looked good,
we then moved on to what we call.
Functional testing. So this is where we connect
all the components together.
And we run a kind of low and slow
test, so for 24, 48,
72 hours we run a smaller number of
game servers, but we run them continuously.
And the reason this is important is you test
that you can reuse matches, you test
it for memory leaks, you test
for port binding issues,
server reuse problems, all these things that
might happen when you're constantly
having players cycle in. Out of matches.
Um, this testing is quite critical because a lot of people
do that kind of big load test through a load of
API requests and go, Cool, everything was green,
and then you miss a critical memory leak or you miss
the second time the server boots up, it doesn't actually
work because it hasn't released its port properly.
So these things are really critical to kind of
test, and this actually ended up
finding a few problems that we then had to tweak and
figure things out, so it was really worthwhile doing.
Um, the metrics we use to do, uh, functional
testing are usually player experience metrics, so
things like time to match, latency,
how quickly I can get into a match, those are really critical,
uh, things for, for functional testing.
Final test, this is the fun one, the large
scale test, right? Throw that lever to a million,
see how much compute we can get. Um,
Spinning up global live service scale
machines costs some serious investment, um,
monetarily, that is.
So you really only want to do this a few times,
um, in your game's life cycle, and you only really
want to do it when you're kind of 90% certain
that both your, um, component and your
functional tests are working correctly.
So don't throw a load of, of money at a big low
test when you're not quite sure that you're going to pass. Um,
this really needs to be your kind of last line of defense.
Measuring for this is all about the outcomes that
we already talked about, right? Time to match latency
is the same as those other tests, but does that
continue to work at higher levels of scale?
We did this test in in super close conjunction with the
Game lift team who were watching all of the stats on their
side, making sure everything looked great and also
with the Reesbourn folks too, so it was a really collaborative
thing um and quite a fun test actually.
Um, side note from us, one of the things that we
really wanted to do as part of that large
scale test was testing it as if we
were in production. Well, what does that mean?
Well, if I've got hundreds of thousands of players
playing a game and I suddenly need to roll out a security
patch, I should be able to patch that without disrupting
100,000 players. So let's do that as part of the load
test. Let's do an AB patch and see how it actually
works. Again, making sure that all those ancillary
things that you need to do once you've shipped a game actually
work at that level of scale.
Some other side advice from from a few years of doing
this is
remember to test all of the ancillary services
that come around the game, so
things like crash handling, monitoring
and observability, all those different parts
of the stack.
Quite often we see that with game launches, the
focus is on. Hey, is the compute working?
Is everything online, and not about all the additional
services. And we've often seen game developers
launch a game, ship brilliantly, the game servers
are working, but they're completely blind because their monitoring stack
fell over. Um, so a really important thing
to test as part of those large,
large scale low tests as well.
So we've built a thing, we've tested the thing
and we're happy.
Now we need to plan for an actual migration.
Um
Our portal tool, as we talked about, allowed us
to move a percentage of requests bit by bit, and
that actually ended up forming a large part of the strategy
here. So we would pick a region at a time
and we would look at what percentage looked reasonable. So 10%
migrated, 20% migrated, 30%
migrated, and we could do it in really slow stages
whilst watching the metrics,
seeing what was going on and really quickly rolling back
if we needed to.
Rollback for this service took around
30 seconds, so we could really quickly adapt
if we were seeing metrics that weren't quite right.
Roll back, have a look at it, analyze it, what
went wrong, and go again. And it just meant that
we weren't panicking because we were halfway through a migration
and something wasn't working correctly. It's fine, roll it back.
Let's have a look at what's going on. And that actually worked out
again to be
really, really smooth as part of the
the final migration.
The really interesting learning from this was not actually
technical at all. Um,
in doing this and being really confident and doing
really small steps, um, we built confidence
both as a project team, but also with Respawn, right? We
were moving their game, it's a scary thing.
Um, we built confidence really early on
that this was going to work correctly. We knew and trusted
the process and everything was working well, so it
wasn't actually a technical reason for this at all. It was
more the human,
uh, element of being able to go, no, we totally
trust the process and we totally trust the metrics and
we're, and we're ready to go.
Some very boring but very important things.
Carefully scheduling all these different migrations
around,
patching, security releases, season
releases, all those things was pretty critical
and ended up with a lot of kind of calendar Tetris,
but again worked really well.
Only having one change go out to production. At
once, whether you're doing a migration or a patch or whatever
was really good because again we made
this change and this thing happened so we could roll it back quickly
or you know we just knew exactly what was
going on. We weren't wait, was it your change or my change
or was it the season launch or this? So once
we planned that carefully, that worked really well and again
allowed us to move really quickly.
And again, very boring, but lots
and lots of maintenance notifications.
Who's doing what, when are they doing it, what's just been
done, what's not been done, when are we rolling back, when
are we not? Really, really good communication
between Rees Bourn and
AWS. Everyone knows what's going on, and
again, everyone can react to the same thing
then. Um,
some final other things, um,
especially when you're thinking about a large migration like this,
um, big capacity planning. If we're
about to move 50% of a location over,
let's make sure we've got the right level of servers pre-warmed.
Do we know exactly what we need? Are we going to go over
the top, or
are we going to come in slightly under?
So again, we had to think quite a lot about that,
how much capacity do we want to pre-warm without just
wasting money.
Um, so that was cool.
And also being really considerate
of time zones.
Doing these kind of migrations out of peak
time zones is great because there's less players, therefore
potentially less disruption,
but then you're not actually testing when the region does come
into peak. So if you're going to do it at the low
time zone, you need to think about how you're monitoring
when it does come into peak and you're at your highest level
of capacity.
Um, so there's actually swings and roundabouts to be,
uh, do I do it in the peak time zone, um,
and do I trust that migration, but I know that this is
going to be the kind of highest player point for,
for the next few days, or do I do it in the low
and then watch later on. So there's a, there's some
considerations to,
to that. We actually picked,
depending on the region, a combination of both.
So finally we started with the actual migration.
Um, we started with development.
Interesting learning here, it was actually harder than
production on reflection.
Well, why is that? Um,
lots and lots of change in a, in a,
um, development environment for a game studio. 234,
1015 builds a day sometimes get pushed
into a development environment when people are testing.
That means you've got QA teams sat around wanting
to test new features, hit schedules,
and it actually means that change and that churn
makes it quite difficult when you're testing new things.
Wait, was the change the thing that we did
to roll out the migration, or was it the new game build
that they're trying some crazy new feature and it didn't
quite work properly, so there was a lot to think about
there. Um,
but in doing dev first we did
have a lot of confidence in the tooling,
um, uh, because we kind of knew how it worked,
we knew the quirks and how things were working, so
um it was really worthwhile doing.
Again, we picked a key set of metrics
that were important to players, um,
just to make sure that we,
we knew exactly what number meant they were having a
good experience and what number didn't, and we heavily
indexed on those as part of all of the migration planning.
um. When there was
an issue, roll back, give us time to investigate,
and then go again.
We prescheduled all of our incidents, which
might sound weird. We call them war rooms,
but it just meant that for major changes and
major rollouts, all of the people that
were there, everything was centralized in one place.
Everyone knew what was going on,
and it meant that we could react again really quickly if there were
any challenges.
And through all of this we use that for
kind of super regular communications with both
AWS and Respawn. Again,
everyone's on the same page. Everyone knows what's happening. Everyone
knows what's going out to players,
especially important for things like community management.
If we're seeing player issues in
a certain region
or the metrics are not looking quite right,
everyone knows what everyone is seeing.
And once we'd actually completed the maintenance for the day
and we'd done that particular region or we'd done
a percentage of the region, we then needed to think
about what happens.
You've done your thing for the day, awesome, everything
went really well. Cool, we're all going home now. Well,
no, that doesn't work. We had to make sure that there was 24/7
monitoring and alerting available, so our
team took over in the evening to look after
those stats and metrics. Is everything still looking OK?
That's when we talked about uh regions coming
into peak so we could check that, oh actually
no, it was totally fine once we had enough capacity
online and things like that. So really, really important to think
about the uh monitoring after
you've done the migration.
Proactive support is super key, so
finding those problems before players see them. You
don't want to see that post on Reddit going, Oh,
Australia's broken again, what's going on?
You want to know that beforehand.
So that kind of breaks down into two things.
One, having really,
really fine tuned alert. On the
metrics you care about, those player experience metrics,
and also having amazing engineers who kind of have
a bit of 1/6 sense for game problems,
watching, being proactive, or that doesn't look quite
right, or this trend doesn't look quite right against
yesterday's trend. I'm going to have a quick look into this.
So really, really important.
And again, trying to do as much
as possible before the actual migration
or a problem happens with the migration, so things like
run books. What are we going to do in key scenarios
if things happen? What happens if this region
fails? Well, we're going to do this, this and this, and everyone's thought about
that plan in advance. Again,
it gives you much, much quicker time to respond.
Escalation parts for each part of that stack
and that service, who's responsible for what, who
are we going to get hold of if, if it's broken.
One of the key things we worked on early on was
having great relationship between partners. If we need
to get a hold of the game lift service team, how are we going to do that?
If we need to get hold of someone in Jared's team or
someone on the cables side, how are we going to talk
to each person and how are we going
to get a hold of each other? It might seem a
bit silly, but it's not always the thing you
think about when you're kind of working up to a big migration.
So those little things make huge differences
in terms of time for response, which means
player pain or lack of hopefully.
And one weird little learning we did find,
severities and priorities.
P0 does not mean P0 to
everyone. Sometimes people call it P1, sometimes
people call it P0, so kind of early on
aligning on what was important and what
wasn't, so that everyone goes, if someone calls out a P0,
everyone's like, right, we're all on it,
there's a big problem here,
rather than a misunderstanding. So kind of knowing
when the problems are going to happen, really, really critical.
Um, one of the great things we built as part of all
of this was really, really strong links into the Game lift
engineering team.
Uh, we share updates, issues we're seeing, problems
they're having, and we get really good feedback from them as
well, which ultimately leads to better
support for everyone,
including, you know, having their engineers on call
and being able to jump on a call at 3 o'clock
in the morning to fix a problem is really, really critical.
So, um, Jared, a little bit about you and
what we actually saw as part of the migration then.
Alright, thank you, uh, I'm Jared.
I'm the head of tech for Apex Legends.
Uh, been at Respawn for,
uh, just over 2 years now. Uh, before this,
I was at Riot Games for about 7 years.
I've been running tech for Team Fight Tactics
when I left Riot, and
before that I also ran, uh, tech for Wild Rift,
which is their illegal mobile product. So
been in Life Service Games for a bit now.
Um, coming in to respawn and
taking a look at what we had, um,
one of the things I really wanted to make sure we had
was,
uh, this hyper focus on,
hey, if we're gonna be moving our game servers off to something,
uh, new,
player experience is the most important thing, um, obviously
cost and some other factors way, way, way into that,
but, um, I needed to make sure that.
Our players were not going to be impacted in a way that was negative.
Ideally they wouldn't even notice, at least on the day
of migration,
um, and it couldn't impact our ability to to
deliver our our seasonal content. So we're live
service game. We're constantly making new changes.
It is a struggle
endlessly to get content out the door, get
that patch out the door. We couldn't have a migration
impact something that was gonna be connected to the features
and marketing that we were gonna be putting for our players,
um, so we're looking for someone that our people
actually can help us with, with, with that.
So that partnership between Reese Swan, AWS,
and Code Wizards was, was, was key.
Um, very early on I could tell that they got it.
They understood what was important to us. They were willing to
put the time and effort into,
uh, proof of concept, making sure that they were going
through, um, all the pieces that we thought were
really, really important.
Um, Ultimately it was, uh,
a very long, uh, due diligence, uh,
with a lot of different components and tests to make sure that.
Um, we, we knew what
we were getting into and we knew that if there
were issues that were, uh, that
we were going to be able to face, we had mitigations for them
and we can jump into that and again, the partnership was
paramount to that. I had uh trust throughout
the entire process, especially seeing
deliverable after deliverable, and then always that
focus on player experience. It just matters that
our players, you know, have the experience that
we need for them.
The most impressive thing was that migration.
There was zero player impact.
Players
moved on to the next infrastructure.
It just kind of happened behind the scenes for them,
and we were able to just do it region by region in a very,
very careful and methodical way,
which again players didn't
notice, but they did notice the other side of that,
which I'll talk to you.
Thank you. So
Not only did they not notice that the migration
happened, what they did start to feel
was the performance increase that
we were seeing here, so.
Pre pre-migration we're
tracking a metric here that you can see on the screen.
This is the um.
The
percent of matches that have a game server degradation, so
something that a player feels that just feels a little
off, it could be hit registration, it could be a rubber banding,
slow mo. There's a lot of different factors kind of
play into that,
uh, but it's a metric we care a lot about because ultimately
when players say fix your servers, they're
really saying, hey, I had a bad experience and
it was something to do
in any type of of of those type of uh KPIs.
Um, so what we saw post migration was
a dramatic drop off in in those degradations,
which is phenomenal. So not only did we.
Uh, moved through the migration,
saw the zero player impact,
um, we started to see the positive benefits that we were hoping
for, um,
in addition to that.
Not only do we have um the the game
servers themselves,
our players are globally distributed. We're
always looking at where our populations are and
we're always looking at ways that we can optimize
what a player experience in any given region could be.
And with game lift and code reserves we're able to
target regions. We could look at different spots.
We can see,
oh, it might make sense to move. Some players from this region
co-populate them over here.
We didn't have that flexibility before and that's really, really
important for us when we think about where we are today,
but where we're going, um, because the game is evolving.
We're always getting new players and we're always looking to see
how can we make the experience globally consistent
for all of our players.
Um, the other side of this is
we're
constantly updating the game.
And in doing so we're constantly introducing
new features, new capabilities,
and that's great for players from having cool
new things to do,
but it also means that we have a strain that we're putting back
onto the game servers. Every new thing we do
could have a performance impact
with the partnership with the
telemetry we have and the ability to see what's happening in
production. We're able to get in front of those
things, put a feature out, have
confidence that it's going to. Form to the uh to the
experience that we're looking for, um, and it can really
lean into the partnership in terms of responding
to those things so we can go back and upgrade
a feature if we need to or optimize it, but uh
it's been really, really important for us to be able
to not only,
uh, take what we had before, move to this new
system, but now we look to the future and we're talking
about really, really cool new player experiences, and
I have the confidence that we're gonna have the game server infrastructure
behind it to do it.
With that said, I'll give it back to Tom.
Yeah, thanks, Gerald. And to be honest, as an
engineer, it's so awesome to see that kind of feedback
when, uh, players actually start having a better
experience. You're like, yes, we did it. It worked.
Um, so we all know that the real
work begins post migration, right? We've done a cool
thing, awesome, it worked, and we're seeing what we need
to. But, um, in the world of games,
nothing ever stands still.
So we've fallen into a really cool workflow, um,
with, with Gamelift and respawn post-migration,
which usually is we've identified
a problem or issue for a customer or even
a developer, right? I don't know how to fix the
game because I don't have the stat I need or I
don't have this metric or I, I can't see visibility.
Um, what usually happens is we build a quick
tool to solve the problem or, or, uh, a
thing in the infrastructure.
Um, what's great is we then feed
that back into the game lift service team.
They look at how they can build that directly into the product.
They look at how they can, uh, make it work for all
customers and make it a bit more hardened and
rock solid, um, and then they ship it out as a
feature. So that's been a really lovely workflow
for us because it means that
the product improves,
everyone wins, um, and we can still
respond really, really quickly to players as well, which is so
critical.
Itterration is awesome.
So a cool few things we've managed to
deliver post launch already.
new regions including local zones, as Jared said,
kind of really adapting where players are playing
and what's going to be best for them.
Adding custom tooling to find those slow-mo
servers, um, hit registration,
all those things are so critical with a game like Apex,
so being able to find and pinpoint and understand
why that happened, uh, just means more visibility,
more monitoring, so we worked a lot on that.
Adding extra tooling for respawn engineering
to kind of get more debugging information when we
have that slow moll or that hit reg issue, how
we, uh, what happened in the code, what
was going on? Was it infrastructure? Was it the code
itself? Was it the new feature?
Really, really difficult to pinpoint that. So being able
to dive in there really quickly, um,
is really important.
Um, and then finally we did also do some cost
reductions, so being able to kind of make the
infrastructure more cost effective, which just
means that that money can get plowed back into players
and on the experience, um, uh,
again, so, so critical.
So, we told you at the beginning that we were going to do
a migration. What did we learn as part of that? Well,
the big things, low test, test and test and
more, right? Think about those three different types of testing,
um, and each of them tells you a different
thing, but be really confident in your infrastructure.
Invest heavily in observability and metrics,
especially anyone that tells you about player
experience. So what are those metrics that are
really key for your players?
Make sure you have those and you're really, you really
understand what they look like.
No big bangs, and what I mean by that is
have real fine
fine control over what you roll out and
roll back in production.
So don't have this big, hey, we did a migration, we moved
every single region at the same time, oh look, it all
fell over.
Be really, really careful and considerate with how
we're moving traffic so that you can measure,
respond, move back if you need to.
And then finally, think about the teams that
are working on this stuff. Build a tight team that really
cares. If that's a a third party service
provider or if it's in your own team.
Um, make sure everyone really
understands the challenge you're solving and why you want to solve it,
and that they're passionate about solving it, because if you've
got that, you're going to do things
much better and much quicker.
So thank you all for attending. Um,
we were so proud of this migration and the
and the and the things that we built here. Um,
if you can please um fill out the
session survey in the mobile app, that would be brilliant for us.
And if anyone wants to talk about game servers, migrations,
or anything, we'll be hanging around for about half an hour afterwards.
Just come and chat to us, we're more than happy to. Thanks
for your time.